but some fool podcast what's a fool
what's up full podcast with Rodrigo
Torres right here in Felipe Esparza at
least over here on the Wheels of Steel
man we get a lot of letters bro what
kind of letters to get rid of you bro
[Laughter]
yeah we'll give it a Lisa Wow Rodrigo
but the roads we go man they really want
him off like I feel like I don't know
that I know that but I just but I just
can't just rip other people who go out
of the way who go out of the way to
start an Instagram page just to talk
[ __ ] like this gathering have our
Instagram page before but you can a log
guard just to say get Rodrigo off I mean
bro you're motivating more photos to get
socially active that's what I'm talking
about man that's like maybe we should
have that dude on he'll know there's a
plan yeah I remember people George is
not happy they want everything a blow
maybe they're supposed to be two five
times a day are they crazy bro I would
have no material left for those shows
I'll forgive that diabetes medicine
issue five times to do a show let's say
that show should be longer I think like
four hours long
there is time April Joe Rogan show is
poor hour-long how come you're the one
or a half listeners old episode a
marijuana talk that long
I hear the video play in our headphones
throwing me off yeah you do my left to
do we're adjusted to do those cheese
but um I don't know man
somebody says save rod save rod their
little bro what can I say give some
t-shirt made man like Save Ferris say
rod Skylar's Empire what's up everybody
we just got back from where were we we
were a letter Georgia
yeah and Austin right before that I
forgot that we didn't thought out that
show bro
well now that she was fooled oh yeah
they're so loud I wasn't it was like
they had a magic trace for us smokin
I said what's up with a balcony
everybody looked up bro nothing it was
covered up with a black curtain bro to
the place where they hold a thousand or
500 the south I thought told me what
babies in the south I thought you was
gonna get your peoples to come down
there and see you work we have more
people to push light all week it's not
rad shoulder that was another 48 hours
done yeah man what's up fool no just ate
it was empty but I was playing because
when I thought that there was a balcony
cut forgot that we didn't sign it out so
what does it give it up for the so we
brought a balcony then it was dead bro
it was like a black curtain but didn't
know and they wanted the show was over
and they never they were cleaning up I
saw that there was an extra hundreds of
these seats can't see you know what that
room reminded me that one that you did
over there in a Falls Church Falls
Church yeah it was just like that yeah
yeah that place won't let your feet
smell like feet they never had shoes
yeah man that one looked well a comedy
club and it still has no super I was
like yeah they used to smoke cigarettes
before oh you know like you know what I
go in now and right into a comedy club
they tend to pick up the key to the
condo and
if the clawhammer smell like we never
changed this carpet yeah
Gallagher threw up here tell ya man I
said in there dude forever like we did
the jukebox in Peoria Peoria that we had
the gun on we're talking to the guy he
said I had I'm gonna get it once and
what happened
I'm a smash like 10 wedding cakes or
something on the stage we still have
frosting on the speakers frosting bro
the sweet night yeah what's up fool I'm
over this Olive illogical things get rid
of Lisa
there's a few I know they don't come to
me they go on the iTunes reviews there's
a couple on the iTunes because I love it
we go together sign up just kind of
tough to go there sign up to iTunes and
leave a comment
I love the negative and I love the
positive because it shows that people
are listening and that's all we can be
involved no Philly's hurt hurt over here
yeah my rent
you shouldn't do though no they're
actually quite positive the reviews on
uh that's right that's right what are
the pain I've heard uh I heard people
like you know suggest update you know I
should talk about and stuff like that
but you know I do we do I do read
comments I read the feedback because you
know I care about the whole show and
yeah I don't I try not to talk too much
but there you go there you go
Jesus Christ could have made one [ __ ]
happy come on not gonna make nobody cry
bro
nobody happen well they nailed that fool
right you can't do anything you can't do
nothing but we will cry about anything
those cried this morning but I want to
bring it up oh no those are crying bro
because uh-uh-uh
anyways man this is personal
follow on Instagram South pit boos my
lady
yeah yeah the Dow Queen bro
she said she wrote this poster people
were talking [ __ ] you know but because
she has a newer a new litter of pet
boots coming out mm-hmm and she wants
five grand for each and every she said
seriously nobody hitting me up talking
about I'll kind of get him over five
hundred two hundred one thousand now
$5,000 a pitbull so I spent too much
money on the breeding you know and I I
don't want to say much about the
breeding but um I seen that breeding
ground there's a backyard or something
or instead of an apartment carpet I
can't give her had anybody breeding any
kind of animal because we have so many
out here who don't have her see him and
that stuff though here in California you
have to be a licensed breeder
you have to follow certain rules you
can't sell like you can't I think you
can't sell them in pet stores anymore
for sure right you can only do adoptions
you can sell if you have a certain if
you're licensed and follow certain
guidelines but then but doesn't matter
like it doesn't even matter what you're
selling or know that your conditions are
we already have a bunch of dogs and cats
and bunnies you know people are breeding
rabbits we have so many [ __ ] rabbits
you know we got Instagram she bought a
rabbit on auction at an auction you know
like you could just drive it by Senate
get off steal something Norco it's funny
all these pit bull breeders or on
Instagram you don't think they're gonna
get busted at some point but I don't
know who's wasting their time water
after and it's all about what
neighborhood it's in how how busy the
cops are there this is that group of a
ladder
uh what's the name big boy used to self
yeah on his elbow yeah oh yeah
to split out the first time I socks yes
Tony erection yeah loco loco city a
booth bro light blue nose bit blue
so what else was she crying about oh the
people cry all the people like they want
to get a pitbull everybody wants a pet
bro but nobody wants to raise it and
feed it everybody was a puppy bro or a
Rabb a B but they don't want to raise it
yeah like I see people broke give birth
and then right away they get a makeup
artist to make them look pretty so they
do know that they were pretty having a
baby
yeah that's the [ __ ] no bro I'm
old-school bro I'm on about the mother
having blood in her face holding that
baby I want to be it is the only it is
the only thing we have left as humans -
that's kind of natural animal
animalistic you know and that's kind of
natural and and not kind of but that's
still very primal I guess it's an order
you really - it yeah and like it but it
was so medicalised after world war ii
you know and people started having you
know getting knocked out to have their
babies and everything but the culture I
mean it was becoming like more modern
and were more Monument more like I
remember my pops you know everybody down
here probably when your mom was parade
he put it was outside the waiting room
Pacey they show the cigarette then times
changed wait at home they do so what but
now the dads are catching the babies and
cutting the cords and really getting
involved on stuff they're trying to get
back to that was my start was born the
first one I saw I saw that who come out
dog like I said a little head and I
don't know
Wow here's curly and that's a little
head come on I'll bloody like hello my
baby
yeah beg you to be given to be all
bloody a low blow
and then I belong in the longest tension
cord whatever you have it
but that [ __ ] cut that [ __ ] dog
and everyone bow save girl I'm legal
court yeah and a little jar a little
matchbox yeah that and they say TV but
now bro that the chick I said a perfect
ass Instagram folder with a baby all
pretty and clean eyebrows no blood a
little puppy emoji on the baby whatever
a baby come on purple bro with blood on
here broad gonna give it to you that you
have blood all over your face it wasn't
yeah it isn't my little shitty babies a
little dirty and the cord is still on
him and you wrap around your neck like
yeah man check on my son son yes
survival like I'm ever like like back in
the day people like what what is our
hack Weller's Junior say yeah I was born
the back of a Cadillac Tom Tom Tom Waits
but really should be a lot of movies man
with a boy like the baby will have to be
born outside like he has to be born the
truck he had to be worn in an airplane
before we land he had to be born in the
[ __ ] up I was started prom but you
know but now all the people are born in
a hospital on TV man there's no like
well now that give you dates like your
baby's gonna be born on this date or
whatever you set it up necessary
incentives which is ridiculous this is
another action rain in this country
difference between hospitals to Cedar
sinai has the highest rate of I don't
know sections and chef told me about
those get c-sections what they call it
be sex like if you're outside bro
everybody with red rags and the doctor
comes out man know how to break it to
you guys I really don't know how to
break it to y'all bloody baby
[Music]
it's a Nebraska blood so it's all this
[ __ ]
the bit man what about my baby I said he
was a c-section but it was lost it was
so cool speaking of Toby Hicks he's
right here lots of bad omen for the
adult dealers podcast people billions
financed yes yes was good oh you gotta
listen you bad yeah yes not oh hell no
kids I had never been to it yes all my
kids was born the hard way yeah Toby had
all my kids you know ultimate bachelor
huh now here the ultimate free man yes
that hello dream I don't even know why I
don't see my kids but uh how many you
got you live my life I have three man
yeah three what I go to sleep like like
I know some parent old me goes to sleep
thinking about his daughters you know
their well-being their man I go to sleep
not thinking about it's a great feeling
it's a great feeling
suck a free bison filly
I don't know nothing about diapers
Similac I don't know nothing about
yeah but then when you get older they're
gonna be nobody to take care your I know
parents with kids they make kids still
won't take care of me daughter's gonna
do him right yeah his son I don't know
but his daughters they gonna dorm right
uncle Toby flush them down the toilet no
no kids man
yeah I'm just it just it happened man
I'm the pullout King wear condoms and I
know how to pull out man oh you know I'm
people always ask me that you're 45 but
you're gonna do I'm kind of 50/50 when I
see half of me do what you know if I
find the right woman I wouldn't have no
issues but if it doesn't happen it does
not also be 45 be too old in a minute
she will be by time you got a plan Lily
you gonna have a cane remember daddy
points his dad was 92 years old and had
a baby with the 23 year old Spaniard
what his new wife had a baby I always
thought he was gay guys can go after
your wife my wife not born yet she's
just about to get it get out of
kindergarten right here do a giant
family forever right party about the
movies Oh Rick Ramos
[Laughter]
how do you still got time drip out what
people ask kids I'm never had a plan to
do I pray that was Cara bro you're so
young you're naive like I should not
even give a [ __ ] about what my parents
thought at that moment I should've just
man up no I didn't have I couldn't
matter because nobody helped me or
nobody told me that shits gonna be
alright we're gonna get you through this
but I was more fear living in fear more
than I think hmm
she was young that girl we worked it out
she probably was 15 or 16 yeah bro you
guys were using like protection or
another would you catch a case you tell
here no it's statutory right yeah but
even though like if you're 18 and you've
been dating the girl before you were 18
or whatever the girls only a couple
years younger than you it's not run by
the parent the parents yeah yeah it's
yeah I remember I'm invited a young
girlfriend back when I was in the
streets hustlin and her parents didn't
care her parents didn't care because if
they needed some money I had it for him
so they didn't give a damn how old I
could have been $40 over there helping
out the family so they didn't give a
[ __ ] the brothers bought a six-pack
yo Toby your girlfriend getting taller
she was beautiful back then she did she
did she referred to you as mr. Tony mr.
Tony I was only out now for a cheat I
was like 18 and she was like 16 that's
right yeah yeah like when I was in high
school and your girl
that always cut class she with my
English class and she had high heels she
taught you touch with a little grown-up
hey she told me her boyfriend was 26 my
freshman year there'll be fools that
were like full-on beards like X drops
with the letterman jacket five six years
I that's really no [ __ ] freshman
that's awful hey hey my aunt had a baby
at 13 and the man was 21 I'd never put
my grandfather wanted to kill that
mother he was 21 and she she was
actually 12 when she got pregnant was
recognizing his 13 which he had to bed
that was the seventies of some [ __ ] you
never say that both about that really
more it was different times there were a
more no rain more than that candidate
that didn't get his election but in what
was a consent right yeah Kentucky - for
a while and they when they changed it
they're like wow that's all cultural I
had a joke about well if California is
our sanctuary for illegal immigrants
this state is a sanctuary for pedophiles
because you guys kept consent to 16 so
if I'm a pedophile California move over
here yeah over there that register right
here they get give me a medal yeah
that's only pedophiles illegal yeah yeah
worry more he was first saying he was in
his 20s and got got kicked out a total
not to come to the mall and yeah that's
but he was already a deputy district
attorney at that right yeah it weren't
some mothers up there going if my
daughter was with Raymore at that age
that would be an honor to our family
yeah kind of like Toby that's a cultural
[ __ ] that goes back to that's like a
window it's based in religion actually
on mirrors children when he thought it
was Dana consummated everything with a
godfather oh yeah I don't remember that
episode
the mayor was dating his daughter or the
console me and then and then I soon
found out that he has like he has like
city rides in Albani I asked for some
likes to be turned down right and they
got turned on the next episode at full
wear a tuxedo at the golf ball they
don't make sitcoms like that no more it
was fun we should have a whole podcast
is breaking down an episode I met some
lovely young ladies and I've been great
relationships it just didn't happen to
her a kid came out of it I'm not some
great girls I've met some some hoes
maybe bad [ __ ] have you tried dating
oh no I haven't I haven't but I've been
hearing good things about it from my
partner over here if you try if you try
to trying online dating chances are you
run into Lady Jane conversation damn you
fat random matches that don't turn into
dates shows that her kids but have you
seen the success story from eHarmony
real people are finding real matches
will eat harmony so we said no Toby
broke free yeah yeah he's been telling
me hey you know I'm getting close I'm
getting warm
no I had no idea cuz I've never done
anything like it I didn't know it would
be so detailed and you know and I'm
trying to get the proper etiquette and
[ __ ] when these [ __ ] come up trying
to court yeah I mean but it was funny
cuz like the first week or so all the
matches I was getting strong women that
weren't attractive so then I start
thinking it says compatible I say well
damn they're not attractive then maybe
I'm not ugly [ __ ] that match up
well together and then another thing is
you know I put down I like sports so
they send me a lot of big women who look
like they used to play football
but I'm coming across some some nice
ones now it is getting better each day
somehow alert you got you got alert oh
this was crazy they send me an email on
this one this was the first time they
had whiskey they send me an email for
being harmony that [ __ ] went off on my
phone it was like eHarmony alert alert
we have the perfect match for you I went
man I start with the [ __ ] I was doing I
logged in man this [ __ ] was about 300
pounds I said [ __ ] the fat people joke I
they gonna do that to me I'm not gonna
come on the [ __ ] a fat girl joke but now
but it's getting better not she and then
she had a nice profile she had a nice
education beautiful everything she had a
cute face was just three of you or did
you mention you have kids oh yeah yeah
put up that's one thing that helped at
first my profile pictures I didn't
haven't but then I put the pictures up
with me and my daughters and I started
getting more hits and some women I've
came at me they're like hey you know cuz
what you do you click smile and that's
how you let the [ __ ] know you can wake
up people and stuff like that yeah you
smile yes I smile I didn't know what
that meant so I smiled back and she just
started she and she was a Latino chichi
she was like hola Toby how you doing hey
I'm starting to get used to it now and
yeah I got a couple of sexy ones on the
calendar on there now that's I travel
cool it was it was just that one that I
tried I went on one day and the chick
didn't look like what'd she look like my
buyer gabriel iglesias he did one too
but it was a back in the days so he
wrote I don't think he wrote roe deer
Elle but he wrote a Latina you know
whatever but but um then the girl showed
up and although a freaking American
woman were real big and her name was to
a comedy show bro mmm like a regular
competition where you don't get paid and
then she stand away in the back and then
the winner go after was
so we're gonna go we like that she said
we're gonna go eat
yeah so they were to go eat somewhere I
guess danny's they give it to the full
date and anyone to go house he still has
sex
Wow okay Oh give me more the open mic
into dinner like this top of her I'm
just smiling at the women now but it was
funny he said
Filipa so Toby when you sign up was what
did you have to take like a personality
test oh yeah it was a whole bunch of
questions I was like wow this is intense
but now I see why it is because the
matches it goes to each one it tells you
what she is and then it lets you pick
you know what race she want you know how
much education how much money you know
the money category and all of that so
you know I put you know why black Latino
age and I got all the women coming
because I don't mind yes yeah I don't
care at this point yeah people always
like and then as people I told that I
was on that eat harmony names like why
are you doing that you know you comedian
you meet women I'm like well you know
obviously that's yeah and I've been
performing a long time and a still
single and long been by myself for years
now so [ __ ] I'm up to trying to [ __ ] I
appreciate y'all hooking me up with a
harmonies yeah hopefully it works out
you go yeah I'm gonna miss it's gonna
work it's gonna work out cuz I'm not
giving up erm it is built to help you
find lasting meaningful relationships
not only a shallow hook-up site they
help they have helped over a million
people find their perfect match in
harmony brains compatible people
together right now my listeners can get
a free month with a harmony when they
sign up I'm free three months per
subscription enter my code foo at
checkout stop waiting and start your
journey to a satisfying meaningful
relationship it can be fun to play
around with online dating app but when
you're ready to fall in love with
someone and have a meaningful
relationship there's
and that that's bill to bring a real
love
a harmony come see how a harmony can
change your life go to eharmony.com and
get started
answer my code fool.com for check out we
should talk about Joe Torre to eat dogs
in Harvey some cyber love what's up food
at your bog what's up dog what's
happening man you guys heard of the
podcast
yeah yeah we did man our dope dealer
podcast the dope dealers are yeah we're
on an episode eight it's so 78 yeah we
finished eighth episode a so we're out
there man we've inspired but you know
podcasts like like you know what a fool
and um the Summoner me and Toby talked
about forward planned it for like a year
year and a half we've been talking about
it and I know Toby City I spoke to you
and you kind of gave him some advice and
um we just said [ __ ] it we're gonna do
it man and we just we finally got it got
it started man yeah yeah man and uh hey
[ __ ] a lot of black people it's a trip
because there's not a black people they
don't even know about podcast yeah they
like what's a podcast yeah
so I figured by the time see we focus on
the Latinos the whites now and by the
time the black people like we'll really
be hitting take off the way it's
supposed to be dope dealers
yes yeah our numbers a grown man and we
just having a great time man and people
we getting a good response we're getting
a good response so you gonna have Spanky
right Hayes yeah we had you know we had
spanked horseback horn spank horn yeah
it's funny they had a little when they
once spanked Hayes been around longer
than spank Horton you know spanked he
stepped the spank Horton said give me my
name you they had a little beef like you
stole my [ __ ] name so no but we
had spank Horton from plastic cup boys
on tour with uh he was on we had him a
couple weeks ago that was a great show
man was talking about the Michael
Blackson Kevin Hart which I heard you
had a little Toby said you you you you
feel that Mike was a off point about one
at the cave and stuff like that
oh I'm gonna have to the Mike Blackson
Kevin Hart little spat whatever you want
all of you so we talked about that and
uh yeah
remember you see ya Bob he threw the
snow the wife out to open for him mm-hmm
whoo-hoo Michael Blackson oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so they had a li edit so
spank was on there real fight or
make-believe fight no it's a little
shade that's like wrestling it's a
little [ __ ] yeah it's like it's a Philly
thing I think it's a little shade being
phone cuz we all go back and we all
started together and but you know it
ain't like I said it to me it's rich
people problems I I'm trying to pay my
cable bill don't ask me about rich
people problems
arguing about our you know are you with
cars me at my might my car opens up like
wings a row of $400,000 Rolls Royce I'm
like care of course he's riding in
private yeah that makes no sense
we sure are you Bob who's gonna hook me
up that's funny doesn't really talk like
that our life black yeah yeah well
blacks and that's another cam kind of
question that black sand is from Africa
yeah and he has originally yeah he said
yeah he's from Ghana he got over to
America I think when he was like 13 now
yes accent but he does put it on deeper
big when when he says yeah yeah he puts
it on a little deeper but you know he's
real African a lot of people have been
questioning it but he's a real African
man how could they question that his
black is easy you might question accent
but you gotta know he's from Africa
black yes I don't think people know he
from Philly but people don't know he
originally is from Africa he came to
Philly when he spoke so nobody's paying
him to live in a hut I can take you some
hoods we look like it's some huts some
houses look like huts that's funny
yes you're from Philadelphia North
Philly man shout to the Eagles and
shoutout to Villanova we we call
Titletown now
you a rocky statue were you from no
Philly you North Omaha yeah and we met
in Norfolk and we met in North Hollywood
no side of town yeah so I'll hit but you
I've been out here for a long time man
and I'm just grinding man but I love my
hometown I wouldn't move back to it but
I'll go and visit but I mean I'm LA now
enjoyed not everything yeah yeah this we
we have we have some issues it's a place
called on fish town in Philly it's kind
of weird supposedly the quote-unquote
white trash is from and that's heroin
city like we have we have train tracks
the train goes overboard so you walk
down there you see needles you see them
laid out they try to fix it they've been
the city is trying to do a lot of things
downtown on legs yeah oh yeah but it's
yeah it's some yeah some we have some
serious here we'll come back but it did
hard yeah you never like left a lot of
dead white people with an epidemic
oxycontin crazy crackhead jail the
crackheads
you know it's weird I probably never
told him by this I you know I'm I don't
smoke I don't I don't do anything I
don't drink I grew up in a religious
family but I look at heroin just I would
like to just try it one time but just to
see what is this feeling that just knows
people up just want I don't want it done
if I could try one time and never get
hook just just I just want this one
feeling to see is this I would I would
do it if I was I don't get hooked on
anything
3000 future spot come back with how did
Mike just Stefano I described it he said
it was like diving into a swimming pool
full of puppies and like floating on
them like to him that was how he was an
addict for years okay but but that first
time never feels the same yeah same with
crack yeah that's the same yeah same way
yeah that's just crazy so different
though Mecca when you when you when
somebody sells you powder they would
give it a stamp or they give you a snap
was gonna be awesome
the rest will be [ __ ] same thing will
actually they step on it one time but
was crack if you if I buy crack from
this guy and that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up and
he's there all night I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna get the same quality of crack yeah
yeah crack is crap but if I look to a
different neighborhood it's gonna be
shitty crack if I come back at 4:00 in
the morning he's not there and his homey
is there his shits gonna be weaker he
gotta make money too mmm yeah man I
don't work [ __ ] I mean in uh and that's
one thing I remember people used to pay
me to rock up they don't cuz I used to
rock it up so good [ __ ] I remember when
they're on when I discovered the
microwave oh yeah yeah I was America you
can microwave it oh yeah yeah yeah when
we discovered the microwave instead of
standing over there had a stove like
making candy isn't it like making like
what I mean yeah come together in the
microwave smooth did you ever imagine
did you have a mess up a batch like yeah
but not yeah I've lost some [ __ ] before
where you just we're just evaporating Oh
jar but back when we used to cook it
over the stove sometime the jar would
get high and they were just crack and an
odd adult would be gone you'd be like
yeah you wait outside Toby it's all
right just let me clean it up that's
fine yes oh those were the days
dope dealers podcast man so uh waste on
ya know with a router down with
additional
under them and though I was walking
cracked with their and that guy had a
bunch of powder but he was not he was
doing it like a uh a real horrible way
to do it
he was mixing he was like up he didn't
boil nothing
he didn't boil [ __ ] he just had it in a
little jar and he put like some liquid
or if it was Dom kerosene I don't know
what it was Oh rock club real fast like
that I don't know what it was though
damn he was oh jeez
[ __ ] I'm trying to think of what that
was I'm like [ __ ] he said he'd made him
rock up like he made a rock up right
there without cooking it up on anything
like acetone I don't know what it was
but he had a little flame but it was
stuff faster and it wasn't baking soda
it was like some some [ __ ] I don't know
what it was was a spray no yeah a human
I can like butane butane yeah yeah yeah
he was a free bait I mean I stood on
that level Richard Pryor level [ __ ] yeah
you know the same she use [ __ ] smoke
that's that's what made crack hit so
hard is that a finger to do that
freebase in know more and put a whole
[ __ ] in jeopardy of burning up so that
that way we'll the butane of that was
stronger or yeah yeah and that's harsher
on you and you could you know that's I
mean that's what happened with Richard
that's how he blew up
there could add alcohol yeah doused
himself a Bacardi 151 yeah yeah she
started stand-up covered in Los Angeles
law started Philly
I started 93 in Philly I did I did my
for I call it my college my four years
of college in Philly you know I came out
here 97 I always all get some 97 so I
just celebrated my 20 20 years out here
I'm I came out here with 1,800 dollars
in my pocket which went within a month
but uh I was out here if I had to do it
again I look back at it you always have
some regrets or maybe if I had to do it
again I probably went to New York first
for maybe a few years before I came out
here but you know hindsight is 20/20 so
I came out here in 97 and met some great
people Toby was one of my first friends
I met out here remember meeting you on
the scene and uh that's the thing when I
came out here you know in Philly we
don't we obviously we don't have a lot
of Mexicans we have Puerto Rican so I
cannot even
it's more Dominican since I left but I
came out here I didn't know anything
about the Latino Mexican circuit and but
you know I met Shang I met Toby fly was
around and I started doing a lot of
Latino rooms and just learning the
culture and everything and that was that
was really high really cut my teeth is
doing like wow coyotes and um Cochino
room all you know all ah ya ya don't ya
don't it's funny I woke up Okaloosa
bastard yes Sebastian shoutout to
Sebastian Bennie man yeah cutting my
teeth out here
don't Latino some rooms yeah but I
started in Philly yeah you started at
the comedy clubs or yeah yeah yeah and
when I started there was only one club
in Philly it was called um the funny
bone
it was the funny it was a mainstream
club and it was they would bring in like
a lot of white mainstream acts every
once in awhile they bring in a Tommy
Davidson uh they brought in a young Dave
Chappelle and I actually did a guest
spot for Dave Chappelle like in 94 only
had like 10 minutes they let me do
he was the headliner and it was he was
the same age as me and I'm watching him
up there do 45 incredible like he was
just you know just as funny now and he
was funny there now I was just amazed I
was like you know he the same age as me
and he's out he's headlining already um
so he had a funny bone then a funny bone
became David Brent aborted didn't became
David Brennan's laugh house then he sold
it and dinner turned into a black Club
it became the laugh house it was it was
an urban club he was bringing urban acts
in it closed down a couple years ago but
now Helium opened up a couple years
before closed down and now you got the
punchline also so now it's booming it's
always Philly's filius a weird tan
because we're so close to New York um
you know we only two hours away from New
York but Philly know they comedy like
you they don't play around like you got
a
even-even I'm I've been in the game for
a while they know me even I still got to
come home and prove it like a
[ __ ]
you've been in LA for a long time are
you still funny listen I got to come
home and prove myself every time man um
but Philly they know that comedy that's
one thing if you can make them laugh I
mean they know they comedy they joy they
know the comics they love it
yeah so it's it's a good town and it's
booming man there's so many shows so
many I never been to Philly just up
Pittsburgh you haven't did Haley your
money no I did Pittsburgh at the
Allentown oh yeah so you was did
surround oh yeah yeah pitch mark is
similar to Philly the Cheesecake Factory
steaks which should you lay better
um well everybody talked about Geno's or
pants cuz they the most commercial let
me tell you something it's some hood
spots let me know better
yeah [ __ ] Geno commercial yeah I'm a
team when you go to Philly I'm gonna
tell you some hood spots I would say
they have the best you know they have
the best cheesesteaks Geno's and pants
are too commercial with the cheese with
nobody does that now I'm gonna take you
to some we go to Philly you come to feel
I'm gonna take you to some hood spots
and y'all love it man sure I don't need
beef but I know that I did have chili
cheese steak here in California that's
now you can add not you you have a
chicken you chicken no oh you are you
are you're vegan yeah also we have to do
a whole like the ones were like that
place there's that place I saw the
pepper steak Los Feliz right off the
tree have a pepper steak sandwich was
just pepper steak with no G but I gotta
check it out
Jim Ellis Lester brother brother River
cuz this place out here call Philly's
best they probably have the closest that
you're gonna get to a Philly
cheesesteaks call Philly's bestest it's
one in Burbank
so yeah but y'all you how are you every
time I like a toe cheese a cheesesteak
sandwich oh we like one that the bread
is oily bro yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah
we have to get you just a whole gear
some like a vegetable whole yes are we
gonna [ __ ] with the cheese yeah we get
you you beef with you be - yeah I don't
really beef I'll do chicken cheesesteaks
a quick question and what's up with the
Cheez Whiz Philly cheesesteaks and the
regular cheese there people are sliced I
don't do the Cheez Whiz to me like way
yes the white trash influence but it was
the one that became more no Cheez Whiz
on mighty steaks no I mean real
provolone cheese come on man yeah my
heart afire all my HUS take on here oh
man you can go online man order this
Missy Mitch is right to the house they
pack them up a nice for you Omar steaks
Omaha Steaks shout-out to almost a bunch
of pepper on top huh yeah you can order
them seasoned or not see that's what I
mean Toronto steaks are the same in
Omaha they're lousy lay it on top that
we got the best beef out there that's
what makes it I mean Nebraska Omaha
steak but no I'm saying in general
Nebraska has to beat best beef in the
country I mean it's known for being
there no argentina's known for I don't
know so are you so dope dealers podcast
I know your history Toby you can listen
to an old episode of what's a fool in
here about it you listen to a crab feast
and hear about his story and I'm sure
you talked about on the show too what's
your history dude how are you related
what did you sell dope you seem like
squeaky clean guys so I don't know like
I don't drink no I wasn't deep in it -
and what we think about it is when we
have dope dealers and what's the podcast
yeah yeah when we say dope dealers we're
technically not saying don't mean in the
domain Toby used to say we yeah we mean
we selling dope conversation don't
comedy
topics yeah but also we have the
background Toby more than me and yeah
[Laughter]
never been in a car where we was been
smoked I have been twice that
squeaky-clean I Drive I rob a Jew
[ __ ] you know I've been in the
Carmel weed being smoked um I got so
little weed and like in college and I
dabble you know I got some drug dealers
in my family and I dabbled in selling
crack for about four three four months
but I was nothing really serious but
yeah so that's the dope that's the how
we came up with it we actually our
original name that we thought use was
the crack dealers you know we have the
dope with a week so I might do some
stupid [ __ ] we had a dope story of the
week the dope question of the week we
usually do the dope seven like 78 dope
yeah yeah we're so fool got these little
comments here Alex cottony latina ha
well jiggle got catfished my tears were
solid nothing but love for you mr.
Torres Opie Taylor yo Rodrigo where's
the truth is that and the guy said Toby
don't discriminate
Toby International and Toby just wants
to eat poor soul a little Mexican John
Goodman Hernandez I don't want a
relationship but I'm tired of going to
the movie by myself
all right hey Tracy i holla at your boy
at y'all know me in you don't have to go
to the movies by yourself or Toby wasn't
new though Trish Hernandez I listen to
part can when I'm cooking hustle town
baby he doesn't look like
good men yeah one good it's broken title
town Pittsburgh Pittsburgh hey listen
your mom Pittsburgh you're my neighbor
we're Pennsylvania homie so I'm not
gonna diss you shout out to the shout
out to Pittsburgh before surgery go do a
Toby impersonation yeah it's cold
oh they're all quiet a little mouse
about to leave it to big notice oh yeah
what's up what listening to you Wow
swinging a sledgehammer my dad cut off
his finger I don't know how to work
that's funny
[Laughter]
David the sledgehammer was my favorite
show back then all right man this is
this do not read verbatim okay our next
advertiser is hims for ball raffles
that's why they were doing the hems
about well I heard last we got to light
they were bored well they're not just
spoiled it's all well male wellness but
yeah this is so viagra - this is focused
on the hair loss okay man 66% of men
lose their hair by age 35 that is Quran
oh that was for me but they do get
havelet's
is that hair light slowly started to
move backwards any bounce pass yet you
know but I noticed that my hair staining
you know what it is Mike I did my Comedy
Central my
HBO special item the makeup girl I told
him I know if the light hits me
he might scalp a lot so go can you do
something about that she's no problem
she she she she she she's brave me bro
so she she spray the top and they make
it look shiny no wasn't shiny it made it
look matte my head so do you want a boss
spot to pop up or do you wanted to do
something about it first you want your
hair attaches to proceed or do you want
to do something about it first
why do you guys turn we're solution into
nothing when they can turn into medicine
in science go-to for hams dot-com a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual awareness for men for him if
you go to him stop it not just for hair
loss
it's for any kind of man problem you
know they're like any kind you need like
an ingrown toenail and I'm the doctor
that they'll see your head you know
they'll talk to you you do like Skype
it'll save you the embarrassment of
recognizing people at the hospital like
you don't want to rise with cheap pump I
wear the hat hey little bear my mail
mail you could get them in the mail no
chance for your face you know here one
of those ice creams anti-aging cream
anti-aging cream I use up I'm a black I
don't need no anti-aging cream did you
get your special cream yeah give me the
black anti-aging cream is Coco Puffs
give me the hard penis and hairline
helper I'll take the enhanced penis help
protect my answer we take bagra
the place is not just where I draw here
real doctors and medical grade solutions
to treat hair loss well-known generic
equivalents to name-brand prescriptions
to help you keep your hair no snake oil
bro
hey we're gonna get rid of your hair if
you only drink this no waiting room no
awkward doctor visits save hours by
going to for hams that come so easy
and now our listeners can go to go to
him calm / that's f o r h IM s calm /
for him dot-com / so go to fo r h IM
dot-com / for him dark comes - let's
read that again go to for him calm / a
fool for him calm / fool fo r hims calm
/ fol there you go she said it best
alright it's just that the yellow I
think was hidden because the yellow yeah
sorry
that's my bad there you go order now by
listening to get on a try off of him for
just $5 a day what my list will get a
trial month for him for just 5 bucks
today right now while supplies last see
website for full details this would cost
hundreds if you wants the doctor or
whoever see no man for $5 you get a
whole doctor bro whole doctor visit man
in a video and take pictures so if I
have a pimple my penis I would take a
photo and send it to them prescription
we would have a consultant consultation
but I don't know if they would want to
see that they would ask you for that he
will say no tell me there's a nude send
this to me okay they call a lawyer
but this way you know if the doctor sees
you by video yeah but he can sue him I
don't know about but now man again like
the because of marijuana issues and all
that nowadays man the doctor the namings
they're innovating in the screen no more
when I got my license renewal the doctor
wasn't even in the room she was
somewhere in another building oh yeah
yeah well they raid the place the doctor
ain't their doctor near the last time I
win either video not went in but now he
wasn't uh nah he didn't he not a team
due to video they just said hey take the
paper and here you go always get the
nurse oh yeah I always get the nurse
practitioner I'm gonna get the doctor
well Chico has to be a woman bro because
he gets homophobic if it's a man I think
all my doctors have been men oh how
about my stars partners Oh any any dude
touch me my feet or my back No but other
than that now when you go pay pay you
don't need a manual strong woman some
swap places they give there you there
you don't know what you want you might
be know well again if a man walk in I'm
just saying like Chinatown where you
don't have to get undressed
you know they just like they'll just
work on your shoulder like we go and get
massages but it's like out in the open
you're just it's called quiet you know
and you're on your separate little bed
that's what Henry you mean like oh
that's fabulous that Springs from China
you mean I got the way they do at the
mall for that relax
man I've had the woman but she's wack I
need the man because on most of the time
the women are too weak I need strong the
elbow bodies leverage I need I got a
weak body I'll take a weak woman no need
no strong man on my back she [ __ ] me
up bro
she was hurting me like I did something
to her mmm I knew it'll be top I figure
she had to put a little extra work in
with you
I remember I'm with the Afghanistan they
was doing massages for like 8 bucks an
hour
yeah we get them every day as I was
getting them every day we like when we
was there there's like 8 bucks an hour
it's like crazy
damn yeah yeah what the happy ending
right on base got the eruption look at
the water I gave you the massage was she
working in the bathing she was a native
or somebody who lives in the city she
was she was in native she was yeah they
were yeah it was right how much did you
tip her $2 Oh $2.00 was big money I was
taking a chance on getting bombed at
least I could do it I was risking my
life over there for the catches picture
of her please I think you know training
I didn't know I wasn't in shape for that
[ __ ] I give me some satisfaction I'm
scared over here
10 with the 10 with the tip yeah if you
asked for it or did she offer or was it
happy no great ladies if your man is
over in Afghanistan this is what's going
on sure that's crazy
man that was good times over there three
weeks of [ __ ] wing night well she uh
Muslim uh I don't really know I just
know she had soft hands and I can't pull
back she took one day off when I was
[ __ ] pissed was like hi co-op today I
had the same one almost the whole time
yeah she was hot Toby they can't see you
well they are were the UH where they are
naked or Eunice our eyeballs like to do
like or they dress that studio oh no no
no they had their clothes on
but they you know you can see that
cleavage and you you could get a look so
that way I mean they show you leave a
titty or another no no no no well you
couldn't touch him or nothing like that
they just touch you I mean I'm sure you
probably could but I was there before
I'll stand in the budget [ __ ] I was like
[ __ ] ten dollars this is cool I ain't
got to touch him that's why another team
cuz hey I wasn't spending that much on
the house did you know you went to Iraq
I went to Iraq with a didn't have a
house it was a comedian I went to Iraq
for a couple weeks it was a comedian
older comedian he doesn't even do
comment that point he was kind of area
Omaha at that point he was kind of going
down I can tell that he really did I can
tell he wasn't gonna be doing comedy
anymore I could tell he didn't have the
love for but he just went over there for
the check so they gave us instructions
you can't mess with the soldiers they
say it's serious don't know fornication
with the soldiers so you only tell me
once I ain't met
nothing gonna I'm not gonna [ __ ] up my
money from the follow the rules so we at
the party after the show they always
show they've had party all the soldiers
with cute girl she was a horny as hell
they know you leaving so she's working
she's working the room she's for tastes
like she's in my face she knows I'm like
get away from me you're not messing up
my $2,700 do not I need this money get
away from me I've been here a month yeah
we was back home I will [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of you but not over here so I depart
I come back to my room like maybe three
in the morning
the comedian room is next to me two
older comedian he comes out his room I'm
going in my room he comes out his room
guess who's behind him the girl falling
on my sword of the last dumbest thing
I've ever heard of us do it every day
[Laughter]
she was breaking it up break it up yeah
baguette about a female comedian would
have a hard time over there man
everybody chasing him
yeah oh yeah man and you know that's
funny about them oversee the military
bases a lot of the women because it's so
you know it's not a lot of women you
know unfortunately some of the women are
not as attractive over there if you and
Iraq everybody look good especially
because I mean it's not that much to
choose from so I remember I was walking
on a base in Iraq I'll never forget this
story and I would say hi to the female
soldiers walking by and a couple of them
didn't speak her whatever so when I went
out and did the show I kind of lost it a
little bit I said well you know I said
man let me tell you some I was walking
around base today I spoke to a couple of
women and you didn't speak why I said
let me tell you something if we was in
America nobody would speak to y'all act
like y'all all of that and right and so
then after the show right after the show
this black General comes up to me he
comes will he pulls me say hey young
brother let me talk to you and I'm
thinking he's about to be pissed about
what I said and he was a general I
[ __ ] you not I thought he was gonna
reprimand me what he was like say that
for 30 years in the States they are
fired they over in a military base is
well they are over there somebody asked
us to sing fire how do you somewhere
request to push-ups hit them note like
right now are when somebody say yes
please I never seen that's why I so you
hate to sing atomic dog
[Laughter]
[Music]
TOB TOB i said that home yeah oh wait I
truly believe imma find my wife oh yeah
tomorrow April 5th I'm in Fayetteville
yeah Fayetteville Arkansas and our
University of Arkansas it's a free show
features students feature the public see
you there
April 12 of the 14 New Brunswick New
Jersey at the stress factory April 20th
Albuquerque New Mexico at least let our
resort' Rodrigo Johnny
Toby May 5th Thunder Valley Casino in
Sacramento area Lincoln California but
we gotta know where it is Lincoln
California is buy weed California May 10
through 12 Salt Lake City and wiseguys
they're a brand-new Jordan landing
location more dates check out for the
people that cover yeah shows coming up
dates will be told me ah [ __ ] I'm uh
what am i doing oh oh next next week at
the 12th we had the Queen Mary in Long
Beach I'll be next the next Thursday you
want to come out check us out you know
next Tuesday I met - ah ha ha pray for
me I'm in the semifinals of the a BFF
comedy festival I'm in the semifinals if
I'll make it to the finals I'll go down
to Miami and be in that so hopefully you
know pray for me everybody out there
where are the finals for that the finals
like in June oh that's not the ultimate
Miami no no American Black Film Fest
they do a comedy competition on Rosie go
28th with you right yeah yeah the 28th
yeah nice lappers yeah Oh a room the guy
had the winner thrown up at a hotel
yeah yeah yeah
but the winner Sheraton right back in
the days yeah it was a hotel he didn't
like kind of like bedico he's doing back
in the day a little is that that guy
with the girl that his wife is the
bartender or something at that hotel and
she's like oh like what you go look at
dude right
no is that do you do show that the
Whittier one time at the Whittier
Sheraton a long time ago we did a show
there and then hit are doing other shows
cuz he did that one that Norwalk they
try to open up a club right I guess I
was yeah yeah yeah that's what he's
trying to do now go check to my head
knee-slapper laughs I don't know Benny
man I was working there a lot but they
split that room though they have like to
show yes sometimes yeah I got two nice
sized rooms you know sometimes they have
to sometimes they'll just have one so
it's a nice it's a nice little spot
everywhere
I will try to open up a comic club tool
together I used to run iguanas oh yeah I
remember that spot that was crazy I went
on for a couple of years they have bad
seating at that place the last dumps
stomp
no I thought you might like sitting on
stones okay I'll be the stay on because
there was a girl there and then she was
heckling everybody when I was up there
bad she ain't called me man she flashed
me mmm and then she she flashed me like
that I'm evil I didn't see anything
then she flashed her her skirt too but
then her older friend Tara Platt all
right yeah right there like on Telegraph
yeah right by the fried freeway the old
early it's very flashy to it then I
remember a lot to Crowley idea will be
sick now old lady's flash you yeah that
woman in when you're on The Last Comic
Standing tour or something like a
piranha Graf picture with olive oil off
the top five you know we're touring in
Florida but then this lady showed up she
had one of those sweatshirts that cat
sleeping on she's just out to other
young little hot chick bro she wanted a
dog titties did you sign them oh yeah
those were looking for change bro we're
getting money people are paying us we
got 10 bucks $9.99 from Trish Hernandez
what a massage her singing oh really
that bright of beetlejuice on Instagram
their penis
99 and then this guy master strange one
I think he's from San Diego South San
Diego California he paid his five bucks
watching on my 4k TV I could see
Rodrigo's I just know hip hop hip hop we
don't know that song Banco that when a
little boy at the park in pecan pork
these to be this cool ass dude bro named
Gary and I used to wear a velvet ass
sweatshirt hello zipper the front it was
brown and it lays right here and into
where the brown slacks with a [ __ ] case
with with red shoe laces broke to
thinking was a blood or something and
then everything was polished bro and
every once in a while now who were some
jeans
Levi's that were not pressed like he
believed us come out but here's a nice
press og 501 yeah and that was chilling
one time bro with this girl and she was
pretty too and then it up and they're
like yeah he was wearing socks bro with
a little boy in the back with a little
ball on the back but you rocking with
your project we're at the park but I
thought was cool with hell man and now
we're walking into it and I was sitting
next to you go what are you gonna pay
right now check this out and I played
peaches and herb and he starts taking it
to dancing with his brush was extra
I was 16 you know we took pass out
lunches for the school and they're like
and they may hurt that man so he would
look come on man
then he'll put my style with a little
toaster oven bro
ah don't take it out and then we'll eat
a hot toaster oven
losers outside are unicode where you are
man you cool without the hustle town
vaping they just give us 99 cents mm-hmm
and then Alex DeLarge
Alex Castaneda I don't know that was him
gave us five dollars he wants told me to
sing slaves song watching you oh my
slave Instagram that one time when
you're singing in the car
oh yeah I was yeah I was fun Oh first
look I would hook ya walking down the
street watching babies go by watching
you 13 more minutes and then we're gonna
pick it up so show us coming up uh yeah
just uh just uh actually I met
knee-slapper this Friday I forgot all
about moving out Reza yeah I'm there
it's Friday and on the next Tuesday is
the big thing uh ha ha comedy club I'm
in the semifinals of the American Black
Film Festival comedy competition so
please come out and you know pray for me
because I listen I just want to get it
free trip to Miami Thank You Man don't
podcast what day did that come on oh
yeah we try every Thursday every
Thursday yeah every Thursday so tomorrow
we will be dropping a new episode
episode seven seven tomorrow and check
us out man support us man we think we
got some some some dope this man when we
having fun yeah learning it's gonna grow
every week so uh we've yeah we'd have
some dope guests man and we're gonna
continue continue to having dope more
doper
guess in adult topics and stuff oh we
did a four episode
seven tomorrow the one we drop and we
did we did a NCAA tournament hood movie
a Linum elimination like you know we did
a sweet 16 all the hood movies we kind
of did like sweet 16 to the lead eight
to the final four
so that would be funny we're always in
her yeah yeah minutes was in there we
put American me in there American me
made it to the lead eight and I think
the finals was boys loser and Friday
Friday and boys and who was the finals
oh who would you Friday in boyhood who
say we pick boys in the hood it's it's
just a hood movie so body is considered
a hood Fridays was funny and yeah when
he pulled out the gun he got a problem
Friday John Witherspoon yeah mom when
they put them up on the wall chilly you
know what I never understood about boys
and hood I asked this question on our
podcast I said uh when Ricky got shot
why did they take him back to the house
yeah why do you why didn't they take him
to the hospital I never understood why
he took him back house they they had a
car ready
that's exactly what I was saying no way
he's gonna show us where shotgun blast
to the back twice well still you can we
in Philly
you can shot in Philly we tried to rush
you the temple house left the car there
around you know yeah yeah I've never to
this day I never understood that
question asked John take you back home
because they knew he was gonna die so
they took him to his mother everything
that was lost you know where angered me
more that movie was at the end man
because even at the end the mom still
blame ice cube for that you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know yeah the mom was
something man my Bob will do the same
thing
forgive me for what did you do I've been
home all day [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
think I do
wish your older brother younger brother
younger brother yeah but you know turbo
so you gotta look out for him yeah you
know also another thing about boys in
the hood Watanuki run Street why he
didn't run zigzag yeah you always gotta
run zig zag see that's when they start
running zig zag I've seen him run
straight I don't know what's going on
what's up fool he'll give us a job with
this border bang bang bang that's where
you got a John Witherspoon story oh yeah
Christmas episode we cut oh man that was
you know what take it that was one of my
most that was one of the [ __ ] up his
times in my comedy career cuz I mean I
was so disappointed in you know we've
been disappointing people for but at
least they was younger people are at
same age but the way he did this I was a
featuring for John Witherspoon at the
Ontario improv it was [ __ ] up all the
way around yeah here's what made it fun
first of all it was it was the week of
Christmas so it was traffic every day
getting out to that [ __ ] whatever then
it was nowhere to park
I'm telling you it like the last show
was like two days before Christmas so
everybody was shopping whatever so I'm
doing the shows with John we do Thursday
everything is cool we do Friday
everything's cool no problems we get to
Saturday and uh I go out I do my thing
and do the same thing I've been doing
have a good set or whatever and I go
back to the green room and he says [ __ ]
you for me yeah yeah there's what he
said let me talk to you and I'm thinking
we said man you did too much time too
much time so I said damn I did too much
time he said yeah you did too much time
I said I'm sorry mr. Witherspoon
I really kidding on him I didn't really
realize I did too much time and he said
[ __ ] you know you did too much time and
that's what really disappointed me and
made me never forget that [ __ ] he called
me a [ __ ] and that's when I walked out
the green room because I was gonna beat
his old ass [ __ ] and that's
I mean that's when I was I was truly
frustrated with him and it's like come
on man you damn near I mean everybody
r4u what the [ __ ] and we ended on top of
it ain't like we going for the same job
like somebody gonna say you know where I
was gonna hire John Witherspoon we're
[ __ ] I would go ahead and take tell me
gigs like that don't even come on that
doesn't even make sense
but you know it's not the it's not just
hearing this it all goes in line wind
unfortunately there's some black
headliners who say they don't want black
people on the show and it's anatta
all of that's that same [ __ ] up energy
yeah that's that uh bitch-ass Erie
Spears can I say yeah that's that [ __ ]
has Erie Spears yeah Arsenio Hall yeah
Erie spears doesn't let any black comics
open up for him which goes to show you
[ __ ] he is
yeah Jimmy Walker Arsenio Hall now I'm
like [ __ ] you know I think that's the
hair liner you you have the right and I
Ares has the right to select whoever he
wants to open up I respect that but to
me you as a black comic you know how
hard it is for you know younger bleep
really younger black time young Latino
comics you know how hard it is for us to
you know get into positions for you as a
supposed to be a celebrity black comment
for you to say
I don't want any black comments open
enough for me that's just to me that
sumbitch the worst thing about John
Witherspoon was this at the time my ex
my my daughter's mother was doing John
Witherspoon's wife here and he's still
tripped out on me like that told me I
did too much time and then I was I feel
so bad I really felt like I had [ __ ]
up he made me feel like I did too much
time so then I went to the sound guy and
I said to him I said hey man did I do
too much time
he said no tell me you did exactly what
you're supposed to do what you've been
doing all week everything's not fairly
yeah it wasn't done by the time it was
you was funny yeah and I was like man
come on dude those people still gonna
take those polaroid pictures with you
after the show
you still don't get $20 from every
person in there for them all polaroid
pictures with the OG camera and you got
your film you're gonna get your bread
you got your bread fave don't mean [ __ ]
when you slam it on stage how big will
his bowtie
in those clown shirts you got a clue me
yeah this brown shirt start okay I've
been wondering this did they start with
boomerang or did they start with the
Wayans brothers show because he was
dressed like that boomerang right and he
just kept that was the line and he was
known for you that was that Friday for
sure that was Saturday first shot
so then I still had to do Saturday and
Sunday so what'd you do this time
no I mean I just I did the same thing
but he did you know it was just I just
did yeah I did a little less yeah that's
exactly what it was and I didn't have no
energy I mean I just [ __ ] me up my
feelings was really hard to think that a
oh gee in the game like that would do me
like that I couldn't believe that he did
that [ __ ] I feel horrible man getting
that from an older guy Oh civil rights
activist ass [ __ ] I was like
yeah I was like damn I walked out of the
green room like thinking slave huh would
you hang on to the weed did you booth
oh yeah I just stayed out in the
audience and then you go and you got
another thing about that he told me uh
don't sell nothing right don't sell
nothing he even allow you to do nothing
so after he pissed me off I was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so I had DVDs I
was selling at the time and what I would
do
he's to keep everybody on the inside the
club taking pictures charging so I was
on the outside the club selling my [ __ ]
I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
so at least I did end up making a good
amount of money being with him even
though he pulled that [ __ ] on me
damn yeah life of as a comedian you ever
been bumped off my shoulder just be
Rodrigo San Diego we were just talking
because he was an extra person yeah I've
been bumped off shows now the ADA the
coldest [ __ ] I ever seen is a one-night
Friday night at The Improv I'll never
forget this [ __ ] when I used to have
Latino night Shayna Rivera was hosting I
think it might have been a possible
refri Friday back we had that and Shayla
was hosting I was on the lineup I had a
group of people that drove out from
Apple Valley they came down for the
weekend to see me whatever and I this is
some [ __ ] I never seen my whole career
okay so we bout to start the show to
showing started Chappelle walks in and I
remember he details the manager he tells
the manager that he wants to do about 15
20 minutes he's about to go catch a
plane and go home anyone to do it cuz it
was a day before it was a day before
Thanksgiving him I mean or the day after
Thanksgiving or something it was before
I day night it was a holiday time anyway
so they goes whatever is so they like
okay with shayla's hosting whatever and
Chappelle was like will not just bring
me right up and he went up he did the
whole show the whole Shayla didn't even
go up we all got bumped that's the first
time in my career when I said the holes
didn't even go up he did the whole show
two hours yes
Wow and none of us winner that's just
yes I remember Shanna was pissed she was
[ __ ] pissed I mean everybody got paid
whatever we just had to leave and all
these people drove from Apple Valley to
see me friends of mine and they were
cool about it because at least they
change to pale so they weren't Dario
y'all come back next week but that was
the that was the coldest that was a
gangster who I mean I've never seen a
host not going with another comedian
Bush up early to do that yeah oh man I
never will forget when Pookie Wigington
chocolate sundae he got in a fight with
Eddie Griffin one stage that house at
the Laugh Factory it was 300 people
wouldn't get off set anyway I'm on stage
but no but see here's
I gotta admit I was a we was all
upstairs talking and Pookie came up to
Eddie it was a Google about ten comics
and he said hey you want to go up and
Eddie said no I'm just chilling tonight
thank you I don't want to go up so maybe
10 15 more minutes passed Pookie come
back by go Eddie you want to go up Eddie
tells him no again Pookie comes back
against his Eddie want to go up Eddie
says [ __ ] it I go up so the Eddie goes
up and now he's up there for a long time
he's disrespecting the light they
blinking alike so finally Pookie goes to
the DJ and makes the DJ turn on the
music damn
and so Pookie's upstairs at the Laugh
Factory Eddie's on stage he's all you
[ __ ] gonna turn the music on on
me you know come down here and in [ __ ]
you know if you wanna do some [ __ ] like
that so Pookie goes downstairs walks up
on stage the next thing I know they
wrestling on stage but the funniest part
is that you could not look in make this
up that they were the same size that's
what made you see look so fun to be two
guys who had a problem that was the same
exact side and finally they let him
wrestle four men in their comics broke
it up but yet actually was crazy Eddie
Griffin wrestling on stage at the laughs
it was like Kevin Hart a little Duvall
fighting awesome yes one more song
searching searching like melee harmony
ladies if you'd like tobe in your you're
on eHarmony give him a shot a shot he'll
be on there for six months till this
trial runs out yeah my be on there till
I find somebody
because this is it seems like the
coolest way because uh any other ways
have not working for me
shut up to ease Oh listening last week
waiting for that shot out what up
widow's motor said you guys should get
on that show under easel shows own we
don't smoke the same show it they should
have be real TV ok be one more they'll
take you one step closer to be real I
know George Perez started he's gonna eat
zone hung old ears on next to me no be
real say man you and I come to do a show
some I care about the hot box I let you
feed table in a hot box sorry
I'd like to see Toby in the car with
[ __ ] be real bro and Jamar coffee
just getting the contact that'll be dope
so every every Thursday this show comes
out I'll be 30 I only unrecorded Tuesday
Tuesday yeah and we consistent we we
heard that was one of your main notes
that be consistent be consistent so we
every week man in some weeks we missed
so we do two episodes yeah then catch up
for that yeah bro so with a yeah bad bro
out there check it out on stitcher
SoundCloud night toots I don't know
mmm-hmm mmm-hmm Elvis Cortez
oh yeah he's from in the band remember
transplant oh yeah
and we're on Spotify two weeks ago right
laughs we got last week announced
released this week
Spotify we're on it's about if I still
listen to us there - yeah Spotify people
was so fool thank you everybody for
being on the show yeah thanks for having
thank you